لم يتم إجراء أي عمليات نقل أسلحة في انتهاك
للقرار 2231 من
قبل إيران ولم يتم تزويد روسيا بأي طائرات بدون طيار
لاستخدامها
في النزاع في أوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى
] وسيواصل اتخاذ خطوات عملية
عدوانية  جعل مبيعات الأسلحة هذه
أكثر صعوبة بما في ذلك
إجراءات مراقبة الصادرات ضد أي كيانات
متورطة
[موسيقى]
اليوم لاحظنا جولة أخرى من
حملة التضليل من
مجلس الأمن من قبل
الوفود الغربية عندما توصلوا في
المجلس إلى قضية الطائرات بدون طيار التي يُزعم أن
روسيا تستخدمها  في أوكرانيا ،
كان هدف زملائنا الغربيين
واضحًا أنهم يحاولون ضرب هدفين في
وقت واحد من خلال اختراع ذريعة مصطنعة
للضغط على روسيا وإيران
[موسيقى]
فئة
مطالبات غير ممولة وغير مؤكدة بأن
إيران نقلت طائرات بدون طيار
لاستخدام الصراع في أوكرانيا ، من
المخيب للآمال مؤخرًا أن تتبع
هذه الدول جدول الأعمال السياسي
في محاولة لإطلاق هذه
الحملة الإعلامية ضد إيران